oh they are yeah three sizes too big but
I want though so I got them oh my gosh
I've done that I've done that I was it
was a half size big when I was like
whatever they're so cute it's fine I'll
grow into them you probably will you're
so tall only 16 that's all hey thank you
it's a good thing well so why are bows
your thing
they were my thing too because I danced
and all that crochet that's how that's
actually how they started for me you
know when I was little my mom I mean I
was two years old I was when I was born
actually my mom just kind of stuck him
in my hair and my joke is as I got older
my bones just kept on getting bigger but
but as I realize that bows are really
like a part of my life I realized that I
wanted them to mean something and so
what I came up with is see one a turd
and so if you're wearing a bow or you
see someone wearing a bow that means
that they are a c18 er so say you're you
know at school or you'reyou're don't
have anyone to play with at recess so
you don't have anyone to sit out with at
lunch with ya
if you see someone wearing a Joe Joe bow
you know that you can sit with them or
you know that you can play with them
because that person's a player that's a
safe place that person will be nice if
you are up for it I might have a little
present for you guys I am
I write you a a bright vote lots of
rhymes I love that it's yellow - cuz
sunflowers my favorite flower oh there
you go I'm so anyway here we go watch
this I had to bring you a denim denim
denim is my favorite color the back show
in the front okay that's a real man
that's letting you touch his cowboy hat
you can sit with me at lunch it's fun I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this